- [Narrator] For years, the cornerstone
of the holiday shopping
season has been Black Friday.
(crowd screaming)
- [Reporter] In Buffalo, New York,
shoppers stampeded at Target.
- And the crowds just keep
getting bigger and bigger.
This place is packed with people
and it has been since five o'clock.
- Not only is it a time of sales,
but it helps people psychologically,
helps those shoppers think,
"Oh yeah, Christmas is
coming, Hanukkah is coming.
I'm gonna be with my family.
Let me start buying things."
- [Narrator] Waking up
at the crack of dawn
to rush into stores became somewhat
of a holiday tradition for many families.
- These are deadly discounts!
(indistinguishable shouting)
- [Narrator] But this year is
shaping up to look different.
- What the pandemic has
done is actually accelerate
the trends that we'd seen.
And that is a move to contactless,
a move to convenience,
really a move toward digital
instead of traditional
shopping experience.
So I think that's gonna
be a lasting change
that we see as a result.
- [Narrator] The shopping
tradition dates back
to the 1920s and 30s
when families would start
buying holiday gifts the
day after Thanksgiving.
Traditionally, this was the
first day that retailers
would start advertising for Christmas.
But by the 2000s,
companies were announcing
Black Friday door buster
deals earlier and earlier.
(crowd screams)
- [Reporter] Target stores
opened at five this morning
and there were plenty of
excited shoppers on hand.
- So there were these few horrific moments
where people were dying or
getting seriously injured
because of people rushing into a building.
- [Narrator] Some department
stores were opening at midnight
and within a few years,
the deals were creeping
into Thanksgiving day.
By the 2010s, the one
day event had ballooned
to cover the full holiday weekend.
But around this time,
retailers were also launching
more online sales on the
Monday after Thanksgiving.
This was known as Cyber Monday
and it was growing fast.
In 2016, Cyber Monday
sales hit a new record
of nearly three and a
half billion dollars.
Digital became much more
important to the consumer.
So what we found was Cyber
Monday actually started
to take on a heightened importance.
- [Narrator] For many
companies, thanksgiving weekend,
starting with Black Friday and
stretching into Cyber Monday
is one of the most
lucrative times of the year.
But recently appetite for
the chaos of Black Friday
has started to fade.
And then in 2020, the retail industry
and how people shopped changed.
- Retailers across the
country announcing closures
and shortening their store hours
in the hopes of limiting the outbreak.
- Add in the coronavirus pandemic
and there are retailers
that may not survive.
- We've seen massive
amounts of retail closings,
accelerated bankruptcies this year.
That means there's probably
gonna be fewer stores
and there might be more of a consolidation
in where people go to some
of these big box stores
that have been open and
operating the whole time.
- [Narrator] During lock
downs in March and April,
spending slid off a cliff,
with a record drop in retail
sales as people were forced
to stay home due to the
coronavirus pandemic.
Between April and October,
around five thousand US stores
went out of business.
But even the retailers that
had weathered the pandemic
are changing the way they operate.
- This year, retailers for the
first time in modern memory,
are saying we're not gonna
be open on Thanksgiving.
Black Friday, we'll be
open the day afterwards,
but on Thanksgiving, deals are online.
- [Narrator] When stores
open, consumers can expect
limited hours and
capacity, curbside pickups,
and a much calmer
atmosphere than years past.
- When folks go in a store,
they're wearing a mask,
they're being counted,
and stores are being cleaned all the time.
- [Narrator] But perhaps the
biggest change of them all,
the shift to online shopping.
A recent survey found
that 70% of consumers
plan to shop online more than normal
to avoid crowds and
exposure to the coronavirus.
But this doesn't mean that
brick and mortar stores
will disappear entirely.
- We mostly still shop
in stores, even now.
Even in a pandemic.
I know folks have been talking for years
about the fact that stores
would just slowly disappear.
Shopping will change, how we
discover products will change.
- [Narrator] And how these
products get delivered
will change too.
As a result of the shift
to online shopping,
eCommerce stores are facing
major delivery logistics
and shopping hurdles this year.
During the beginning of the pandemic,
consumers were faced
with month-long delays
as ports closed and
supply chains broke down.
Now the question is
whether shipping companies
can handle the mass
influx of online orders
that are expected over
the next two months.
- A big reason that
retailers are pushing people
to shop online early
is to spread out sales
and give a little breathing room
to the eCommerce supply chains.
- [Narrator] But right now,
the numbers don't look too promising.
The shipping industry is expected to be
more than four million
packages over capacity
during the peak of the
holiday season this year.
- It's gonna be really
hard to order something
two days before Christmas
and have it arrive.
That literally might not be an option
even if you're willing to
pay 50 bucks for shipping.
Because there won't be
capacity to get it to you.
Which could push people to stores.
- [Narrator] But at the same time,
many have lost their jobs
due to the pandemic this year
and may not have the ability to buy gifts.
- We have around 20 million
people on unemployment.
There was a little bit of
a false sense of security
that came because we got big
stimulus checks in the spring.
There was additional unemployment
that people were getting
until the end of July.
A lot of that is gone or up in the air
and hasn't really been resolved.
So, retailers are definitely
ready for lots of consumers
not to feel like buying at
all or buying a lot less.
And even for folks who have jobs,
I think my sense is talking
to retailers and consultants,
those folks are saving a lot more,
which points to a little bit of caution.
- [Narrator] This means
that certain retailers
that cater to pandemic living,
like groceries and home improvement,
could continue to see profits
while those that would
traditionally see big sales
around Black Friday, such
as clothing and toys,
could see bigger losses.
The past year has upended
the retail industry
and shaken up what is traditionally
the biggest sales period of the year,
but most notably, 2020 has solidified
the trend towards online
shopping as a permanent part
of the retail industries future.